CLINICS.
THAT’S THE PLAN.
WILL IT WORK.
THAT’S WHY WE ARE INTERRUPTING
UP THE HEARING FOR JUST A MINUTE
TO BRING IN HEALTH SECRETARY
ALEX AZAR.
WE SHOULD MAKE A MOMENT TO
CELEBRATE THE INNOVATION OF THE
SCIENTISTS HERE IN AMERICA AND
THE PARTNERS THESE COMPANIES
HAVE.
>> ABSOLUTELY.
PRESIDENT TRUMP DESERVES THE
CREDIT FOR BASICALLY CONCEIVING
OF THE POSSIBILITY, THE VISION
WE COULD GET A VACCINE WITHIN
A YEAR.
INSTEAD WE HAVE IT WITHIN 10
MONTHS.
THESE ARE NOT JUST ANY ORDINARY
VACCINES.
THANKS TO OPERATION WARP SPEED
AND THE EFFORT TO SCALE UP
MANUFACTURING AND RUN 30,000
PLUS CLINICAL TRIALS, THESE ARE
OVER 90% EFFECTIVE VACCINES.
THIS IS BIG NEWS.
>> Dana: IT IS.
YOU HAVE THE 2 COMPANIES AND
MAYBE MORE WILL HAVE EFFECTIVE
VACCINES.
HOW DO YOU FIGURE OUT A WAY TO
MASS PRODUCE ENOUGH?
10 MILLION DOSES IS NOT ENOUGH
TO GET EVERYBODY TAKEN CARE OF?
DO THEY POOL RESOURCES AND SHARE
INFORMATION?
>> THIS WAS THE GENIUS OF
OPERATION WARP SPEED.
WE BEGAN MAKING THESE DOSES EVEN
AS WE WERE TESTING TO SEE IF
THEY WOULD WORK.
WE ALREADY STOCK PILED MILLIONS
OF DOSES OF BOTH VACCINES.
WE ARE MANUFACTURING 4 OTHER
VACCINES IN OPERATION WARP
SPEED.
THAT’S WHAT WILL ENABLE US FOR
MODERNA AND PFIZER IF THEY GET
FDA AUTHORIZATION, WE WILL HAVE
40 MILLION APPROVE DOSES BY THE
END OF DECEMBER.
IT WILL KEEP GOING MONTH AFTER
MONTH.
MORE PRODUCTION.
>> Dana: WE KNOW THERE ARE THE
TIERS OF WHO SHOULD GET IT
FIRST.
HEALTHCARE WORKERS AND THE
VULNERABLE.
YOU HAVE FIGURED THAT OUT.
MY MOM AS AN EXAMPLE.
EARLY 70s.
DENVER, COLORADO.
VERY MUCH WANTS TO GET BACK TO
HER LIFE.
AT THIS POINT, HOW DOES SHE
CHOOSE WHO TO CALL TO GET IN
LINE TO GET THE VACCINE?
WHICH VACCINE TO GET?
HOW DOES THAT WORK?
NOW THAT IT’S MORE REAL AND IT
LOOKS LIKE WE WILL HAVE THIS
VACCINE, YOU GET DOWN TO THE
NITTY-GRITTY OF HOW DO YOU GET
IT DONE?
>> YES.
IT WILL BE A CONTROLLED
DISTRIBUTION APPROACH AS WE HAVE
MORE LIMITED SUPPLIES IN THE
FIRST COUPLE OF MONTHS.
WE WILL FOCUS ON THOSE MOST
VULNERABLE AND YOU MENTIONED
A COUPLE OF THEM.
HEALTHCARE WORKERS AND THEN OUR
MOST VULNERABLE.
INDIVIDUALS IN NURSING HOMES AND
ASSISTED LIVING.
WE WILL LOOK AT THE DATA AND THE
CDC WILL MAKE RECOMMENDATIONS 0
TO SEND IT.
WILL BE VERY CONTROLLED
INITIALLY WITH THE LIMITED
VACCINE.
>> Dana: MY MOM SHOULD NOT CALL
HER DOCTOR AND ASK TO BE PUT ON
A LIST FOR DECEMBER 20th?
>> THAT’S RIGHT.
THERE IS NO WAITING LIST OR
PROGRAM LIKE THAT AT THIS POINT.
WE WILL MOVE IN THAT TYPE OF
GENERAL DISTRIBUTION MOVING INTO
THE MONTHS AHEAD.
INITIALLY IT WILL BE VERY
FOCUSSED, NURSING HOMES AND SIFT
ASSISTED LIVING AND EMERGENCY
FIRST RESPONDERS.
WE USED TO GET 90 MILLION
VACCINE FOR CHILDREN OUT THROUGH
THE CDC AND 170 MILLION FLU
VACCINE EVERY YEAR.
>> Dana: RIGHT.
I PARTICIPATED IN THE PANDEMIC
EXERCISE IN 2005.
WHEN IT GOT TO THE PART THERE
WAS THE DISTRIBUTION, THAT WAS
ONE OF THE MOST INTERESTING
THINGS.
HOW YOU GET IT DONE IS A SUPER
IMPORTANT PART OF THIS.
THERE IS POLITICS GOING ON.
PRESIDENT-ELECT JOE BIDEN
YESTERDAY SUGGESTED IF THERE IS
NO COORDINATION MORE PEOPLE
MIGHT DIE.
TAKE A LISTEN.
>> MORE PEOPLE MAY DIE IF WE
DON’T COORDINATE.
IF WE HAVE TO WAIT UNTIL JANUARY
20th TO START THAT PLANNING, IT
PUTS US BEHIND OVER A MONTH AND
A HALF.
IT’S IMPORTANT THAT IT BE DONE
AND THAT THERE BE COORDINATION
NOW.
>> Dana: DOESN’T ALL OF THAT
PLANNING CONTINUE REGARDLESS?
YOU SAID OPERATION WARP SPEED IS
IN PLACE FOR ALL AMERICANS.
IT WOULD JUST CONTINUE TO MOVE
FORWARD WITH NO INTERRUPTION.
>> YOU’RE ABSOLUTELY RIGHT.
PLANNING DOESN’T BEGIN ON
JANUARY 20th.
PLANNING BEGAN MANY MONTHS AGO.
WE PUT OUT 64 PAGES OF DETAILED
SPECS TO STATES AND LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS.
I HAVE A COMPREHENSIVE
DISTRIBUTION PLAN.
WE WORK WITH EACH ONE.
THESE ARE CAREER PEOPLE AT CDC
AND OPERATION WARP SPEED THAT
ARE WORKING ON THAT.
THEY CONTINUE NO MATTER WHAT.
THERE WILL BE CONSISTENCY AND
PROFESSIONALISM.
THE DISTRIBUTION PROGRAM WILL GO
ON UNINTERRUPTED.
>> Dana: SECRETARY AZAR WE